you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Ches comm
and I'm playing a five-o game let's see
what we get
let's try well maybe a benoni
yeah why not let's let's you for a
Benoni
yeah let's go for it let's see how white
reacts and d5 or not okay
we're taking and I've played this snake
benoni before with Bishop to d6 but
against this of fianchetto I'm uh I'm a
fan of just going with
d six and without the bishop eyeing up
the be five square it may be a little
bit easier for me to push through with a
queen side expansion so let's get some
baby moves in here work on eh-eh
I'll probably hold off on where I want
to go with him just yet he'll probably
end up going here now you know I'll play
a six first I was thinking
somehow there might be an option to go
night a6 into B for but that's never you
know I'd have to first threaten to be
getting in b5 successfully for them to
play a4 and stuff to do that so start
with rook to e8 seem sensible half-open
file
I would like to trade one minor piece so
we might have a little bit of a battle
going on with that soon Knight c4 Knight
here let's get this move in I have to be
in a position to meet Knight c4 with
Knight to e5 prepping b5 right now so
let's sneak this in I think it's very
important
they were threatening on d6 and also
some added pressure okay that move um
what do I do in reply to that
flush my night away with f4
pushed through somehow if I put my
bishop here f4 is going to end up
trapping my knight I'm a bit clogged up
mmm Knight to a3 yes
okay let's try let's try this move I
have to be really really timely here so
I think me with f4 I go back to d7 and
if they return to c4 now I could get
this end also Queen c7 is facilitating
c4 and I think I should do that right
now and with this I'm opening up this
dog and also I may be threatening to
play b5 okay they're covering that
diagonal I think I have to jump in here
so if I play Knight to c5 I think II
five is hitting ninth c5 e 595 a five
and if I take there's d6 hmm okay I
think I might have to go about it this
is tricky alright I just um I'm still
going to go in here and meet a five with
my other Knight to d7
I am on e4 twice you know they could I
could go upon hunting here for sure yep
alright I think I have to break up the
Pandu on now on d6 I could go elsewhere
let's see okay
and on that moon I think I have to press
forward with e4
I don't want them to blockade and I want
a square that I could jump to on d6 this
is extremely sharp yeah we're clearly
going down some really critical line
Queen to d5 I was not expecting that so
preparing the capture and then capture
on f7 yeah that's a really good move
Oh
yeah okay so I guess I have to defend f7
let's see they could win this guy here
what am I missing with that move I have
to take oh they're on c5 totally mess up
there on c5 as well they're not winning
a piece they're just going after this
brutal men brutal okay I'm play on a
little bit more why are they waiting
forever to take my knight that's a very
good question
wasn't that the only move I could take
on e4 I cannot take on b2
I guess we're going to go back starting
to win their night they're not going to
fall for that surgeon a surgeon is what
we have here 207 I have to try to
outlast them on the clock that's all I
could try to do let's get rid of that
night
I don't even have a spot for my Queen to
go to another curious moment I'm not
sure what they were thinking of
besides the recapture on e4 yep and
reminding me that f7 is a soft point I
got a return here this Knight is well
worth the you know he's far more than
three points clean there whoo yeah
okay
let's maybe make my first active move
get at g3 take on f7 I imagine you know
it could take on f7 if I go to a dark
square they have this got it all worked
out
so I can run into a discovery
unfortunately one minute 33
how to run here and where's the where's
the killer move you just jump in here
yes everything is a killer okay let's go
here
can I outlast them on the clock Wow okay
really
squares I guess here then night here a
check gotta go here
what is the finishing finishing touch
another check
gotta go here yeah and now that move is
my queen
trapped not yeah wow she is really short
on squares I guess here yeah I guess
here here a check on H five I guess it's
a mate from this point they're going to
get on the diagonal night to each five
and then a queen here
and that's going to be ball game or here
made on the spot okay yeah I don't even
know if I want to review this game I
have a just a really weird feeling about
this one
I don't know let me go into the let me
go into the analysis I must be said I'm
a bit flustered right now because I
don't know it's just when you're at the
game long enough and
I don't know what to say what to say
what to say you kind of have a a sixth
sense when it comes to some games and my
opponent played really good is what I'm
trying to say this account played really
good so let's see yeah let's let's just
I want to see how many moves are top
moves this is a little bit of a test
here yeah AB b5 is a move I was just
looking at this the other day when a g3
is in before Knight to c3 b5
that in I'm curious about the middlegame
position where it's really sharp many of
these moves are top moves
I'm pretty sure it just seemed really
really really accurate and I don't know
it's just kind of curious that some some
moves are you know only recaptures and
they're not played like straightaway but
anyhow a six
and I could have I was not successful
with organizing my pieces I wasn't able
to exchange off a minor piece so I
wonder how I could have approached this
a little bit different this is all very
common for white to reposition the night
into c4 and target d6 and also this idea
of night 283 so I applied I played rook
to b8 isn't there's no issue with this
just yet but right around this point 9
to see 495 is fine in 99 to 83 is uh
I've been in this position before is
white this it's a very nice idea to
avoid the knight exchange 9 to 83 and
then in comes this idea of f4 and then
the knight returns I'm lacking space so
I really don't have too many squares to
move about on with 4 minor pieces that's
why I'm really gunning for some kind of
a peace exchange so f4 Knight back to d7
and I think we're student at a point
where I'm just busted and maybe like
right around here actually II for I felt
like I had to go with c4
and uh okay they why play Bishop to e3
next but I was saying that there might
be some tactic connected with b5 just to
illustrate this this b5 takes takes is
not quite working because capture
capture capture Queen check the knight
can return to d4
at minimum apparently there's also a
Bishop to e3 but you know that's one of
the ideas behind this c4 move open up
the diagonal especially now that they
white has moved the F on the diagonals
open so I played c4 Bishop to e3 is very
sensible developing and covering that
diagonal 95 so far ok it likes night to
c5 but now this is where it's really
getting crazy sharp with E 5 and that's
like I guess I can only move e5 anything
else and then I start to be a little bit
better with Bishop to f5 taking
advantage of this unprotected Bishop on
e 3 E 5 and ok I guess my reaction here
is and it's just gone after my next move
and form over way out
move 18 the answers gone from here I
needed to play I need to jump into
Knight to b3 and what's the what's the
story if they take here correct take Z 3
and they take my bishop and I take the
rook oh man I do not want to give up my
dark square bishop like that Knight
takes a 1 clean takes Knight
yeah no idea how to assess this one
unfortunately these Knights are not
close to my king but we had to give up
that dark square Bishop is kind of scary
dynamic equality is that what they say I
guess so after my move it's gone so
let's see these next moves Knight to d7
Knight takes e4 and I'm just curious if
every move is like a top move here f5 e
4 and we have d6 top move Queen to d8
and now this has been as a really strong
move Queen to d5 I would have guessed a
Knight jumps into d5 but yeah Queen a d5
another top move ready to take pounce on
f7 and I'm just playing on what feels
like not even three ranks like two ranks
just crawling up into a ball it's not
fun and from here f6 not a top move you
could have just picked up the night on
now
c5 oh well there you go now f6 is
considered a top move okay
f6 is in chop and now rook takes f6 and
recapture and then then a capture on c5
of course and I'm recapturing and what
more from here yeah Queen takes e5
pretty much the only move took about
four or five seconds to pull that one
off
uhh
trip to e6 yeah I'm just testing to see
the top moves 9 to be 694 something
around the same shop
I gotta go back there's just no good
squares at all and night C - D - or
night - v6 our next night to be six this
is a a monster and a howl
nothing for me to do here just a growing
advantage wreck f1 I take them out and
how much longer
yeah Bishop to d5 I got to go back and
then Queen to c7
yep Queen c7
g5 and how much further we go here
bishop takes f7 is working I go to any
of these the Queen goes to c3
well if I go to the corner I should say
going to c3 is going to hurt me so I got
a book clean c3 and my queen is so short
on squares h4 90 d7 what was played here
Knight to d7 and what next
h4 clean g4 we're almost there until the
mate and it's a mate and nine right now
Queen e2 e3 King to g7 just announcing
the middles now not much more to add
yeah King to H 6 million 7 9 to have six
top move and a nice little night to
finish here with going to g5 only move 9
2 H 5 and then we have makes a couple
different ways okay what more to say I
played against a really strong account
hopefully you're still able to maybe
take something away from this the benoni
it could very easily go wrong I was not
successful with trading a minor piece
and I was very cramped as a result did
not react properly to this e 5 move I
really needed to take it into sharp
waters right here and calculate some
with Knight to b3 but you know with how
well my opponent calculated in this one
I imagined I would have ended up in the
same boat getting mated one way or the
other okay as usual if you have any
comments feel free to leave it in the
comment section below
hope you're having a great day in I'll
catch you soon that's all for now take
care bye
you